hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan Seibert
we're gonna start off our little III
Athan 2015 Athan with the halo 5
gameplay demo I like the live action
special trailers they've been showing
for this we're really good yeah and now
we're taking a look at the gameplay
let's do it
let's get your brain to it [ __ ] donata
defensive positions looks really good
and it's not feeling really smooth yeah
and it's not like generic lock turn you
sure let's see activating the Artemis
it's it we're playing on replay yeah do
you see this too
Jesus all rifle no Emma then the Master
Chief's been through here which means he
has a head start on the guardian
let's get moving goodbye for this moment
of long time the covenants finally
breaking you see trailer you believe
Jesus in the story yeah big the chains
already on board
you gotta keep up with the chief Oh
[Music]
[ __ ] got jet packs or you get Jeff back
yeah no I'm pretty I'm gonna find out
right now one would assume you get a jet
pack as well you're a lot more dialogue
yeah there's a there is
[Music]
that's cool I did maybe yeah excited
crumbling building they plane live right
now they're playing live right now
they're doing the coop oh yeah
so you can have up to four players on
coop story - is it gonna be that good
it's phenomenal Slayers weirdly yeah
yeah it jumps you tuned like 60 frames
and like yeah yeah that's the purpose
the thing that's like tripping me out
yeah looks good 60 frames another dead
[Music]
weapon cache up there there they're not
gonna flank left
bulkhead up with me
[Music]
this has got a lot more formidable oh
yeah it's not just some time no we asked
Joe
so that's definitely a new gun
[Music]
in the dear
[Music]
Oh
your captain deck take them Sam
Oh [ __ ] how to achieve this call but
you know passengers do now
[Music]
[Music]
we need to get airborne
we are airborne water shake dog
that looks pretty sweet that's pretty
cool that looks pretty sweet man it's
just like traditional halo but improved
upon me you know there's definitely like
small little bits that kind of make me a
little more excited to play the game in
the fact that it's not just those halos
been very much kind of like a corridor
battlefield and like there's some very
basic maneuvering this one has a lot
more like places to go which I'm kind of
digging right now and you brought a
platforming which is pretty cool I mean
it makes sense why they gave him a
jetpack now yes it it just super jumps
kills me you know in Halo 4 oh my god oh
I don't get this wrong but like the
jetpack was a special ability you got
and you had to like use it this one is
more like you get a double jump standard
which is a like especially with destiny
a lot of these games now that have like
a standard double jump in their gameplay
it definitely feels better oh yeah
the single jumps really would have [ __ ]
you over sometimes man it looks pretty
standard those live-action trailers got
me super pumped and that one was very
much like okay though yeah that wasn't
okay like it's felt a little generic but
like this is like their first gameplay
trailer so who knows maybe they'll add
more to it but but I kind of don't ever
mind that with halo halo horse I'm gonna
buy halo because I want a good
multiplayer you know like a fun rkd
multiplayer game yes exactly what halo
is and it's one it's one of the best
first-person shooter games and when you
play Halo 1
the controls are awesome so I'm like I
kind of don't want them to [ __ ] around
with stuff don't look to much all I can
do really is offer a little something
new each time and that's what that are
doing so I don't mind it but I could
still the same time see how it upsets
people it just feels like the same game
yeah you grab it like I like you're
gonna halo again
I love
that's good anyway guys thanks for
tuning into the reject channel you know
what you can do you get subscribe to the
real rejects you can also check out
dance Irish Channel that's me that cyber
channel you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter and vine trying to
get more product placement I already got
product placement a few times and people
don't know which ones are real and which
ones are not except for the one that I
did recently I guess keep a lookout for
the product placements people keep a
look at it you can where's walk oh yeah
I want you guys to be able to guess Luke
at her and Taylor love your videos Ryan
you know one of my favorite
personalities on YouTube I'm an artist
on YouTube excuse me I love your sense
of humor keep up the good work man well
Luke Kanter and Taylor thank you so much
my friend Luke Catherine Taylor he was a
Irish boy who grew up in Ireland really
being raised to be a priest until one
day he met a woman redhead fire-crotch
and he just had to have that vagina and
you know he was about to become a priest
when said he [ __ ] this girl realized
hey man I would do this for the rest of
my life now he has a sex addiction and
now you can find him at the pub every
night drinking Guinness you really
wanted to insert that joke there I like
get it